hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
critical reagent characterization and
candidate selection
powered by the uncle platform i am
jennifer woods of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
unchained labs to learn more visit
unchainedlabs.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
ron bauscher partner and cso
at b2f life sciences adam kinney
scientist custom reagents for b2s life
sciences
and dr kevin lamp marketing manager at
unchained labs
kevin you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for that introduction i'll be
introducing and giving some more
background to the thermal unfolding and
aggregation parts of this webinar
and the instrument used for much of the
analysis that you'll see
so when dealing with a hard choice
between a lot of options for
proteins as critical reagents picking up
just
one best option can feel leave you
feeling a bit like the statue on the
left
overwhelmed in this webinar myself ron
and adam will talk about how
characterization
using the uncle from munching labs can
help you id
the best performing options
when thinking about the stability of a
protein we can summarize it as
two different types of stabilities
conformational
and colloidal conformational stability
shown in blue on the left is the ability
of the protein to stay folded in its
native state
thankfully examining protein
fluorescence is one way to get insight
into the conformational stability of a
protein and is an easy way to examine
thermally induced unfolding colloidal
stability
shown on the shown in green on the right
can be thought of as the aggregation
behavior of a protein
gathering size information from static
and dynamic light scattering
can inform the understanding or
protein's colloidal stability
and both of these behaviors combine to
paint a fuller picture
of a protein stability that you can use
to pick the best option
so that leads us to the uncle and its
ability to gather conformational and
colloidal information
to paint a fuller picture of protein
stability uncle is an all-in-one
multi-modal biologic stability platform
that combines three detection methods
in 12 applications to help you
understand the stability and aggregation
behavior
of your proteins in critical reagents to
test any of these applications
only 9 microliters of sample is needed
and up to 48 samples can be run at once
those three detection methods on the
uncle are full spectrum fluorescence
static light scattering or sls and
dynamic light scattering or
dls uncle can see the full spectrum for
fluorescence to give you the option to
look at protein intrinsic fluorescence
which evaluates usually tyrosine and
tryptophan fluorescence
or use any of an arsenal or fluorescent
dyes
simultaneously with that fluorescence
measurement you can use static light
scattering to monitor
how the same sample aggregates occlude
uses sls at two-way lengths so you can
track small and large particles at the
same time
dynamic light scattering or dls is
uncle's third detection method and is a
highly sensitive technique to give you
details about your protein's
size and size distribution so besides
gathering size data
dls is powerful for understanding what's
in your sample and it can be used to
quality check proteins
either independently or before you start
a thermal stability experiment
now i'm going to introduce one of the
key features of the uncle which is the
uni sample folder
the uni is composed of an array of 16
quartz micro cuvettes that are easily
loaded with the pipette
the high grade quartz gets us great
optical sensitivity for fluorescence and
light scattering data
and the frame is an anodized aluminum
that provides efficient heat transfer
once you load each of the wells the unit
is then clipped together in the blue
frame you see at the bottom of the slide
where the silicone seals provide a nice
tight seal around each of the unit
cuvettes
this means that you can read a unit
right away or you can pop it into and
out of an incubator
or fridge and take time points over a
long period of time
now a little bit of detail on the
underlying phenomenon of protein
fluorescence
here we're looking at the three
fluorescent amino acids in a protein
tryptophan tyrosine and thermology in
blue we have the absorbance
spectra of each amino acid so when we
hit these proteins with a 266 nanometer
laser that's in the ankle
it will absorb the light from that uv
laser and fluoresce it which is what's
shown in green
uh altogether all of those amino acids
inside of a protein
combine to be the intrinsic protein
fluorescence and the important part of
this
is as proteins unfold that intrinsic
protein fluorescence will change
so you'll actually see changes in the
combined
green fluorescence behavior
we see that change here on the slide so
over a heat ramp uncle will excite and
read the full spectrum fluorescence of a
protein sample
at numerous temperatures each line in
this graph
is a fluorescence read approaching
excited with that 266 nanometer laser
starting with the rate at 50 degrees
celsius and going all the way up to 95
degrees celsius
you can see by following the curves from
top to bottom how they shift to the
right side of the graph
which are the longer redder wavelengths
this phenomenon is called a red shift
and occurs because the protein is
unfolding
barrier tryptophan residues have a shift
in fluorescence emission
as they move from being buried in
hydrophobic pockets to being exposed to
an
aqueous environment as the protein
unfolds
this protein shows a classic redshift
pattern but you never know how each
protein will behave until you've tried
it
some proteins shift to the left called a
blue shift while others can
decrease in fluorescence without a shift
with
uncle's way of collecting full spectrum
fluorescence you have all of the data
and you don't have to worry about
unexpected protein behavior
and for proteins without tryptophan and
tyrosine residues uncle also has a 473
nanometer blue laser
that can be used with cypro orange dye
to excite fluorescence and determine
unfolding
the analysis method we recommend reports
the barycentric mean
of that full spectrum fluorescence this
is shown on the left
it's the wavelength that evenly divides
the area under the curve
as a kind of spectral center of mass
we found that this analysis method is
the least acceptable noise
since it integrates a large range of the
fluorescent spectrum
analysis of the protein fluorescence
then is used to show
unfolding and identifies inflection
points as melting temperatures of that
protein
we see results of that kind of
experiment here where in blue we're
looking at the bcm data
and in green we're looking at static
light scattering data
these pieces of data are gathered
simultaneously so you understand protein
thermal stability and aggregation
information
in the same experiment on the same
sample red all at the same time
so fluorescence in this case the blue
data shows our proteins unfolding
and we can see inflection points that
are identified as melting temperatures
at tm1 and tm2 the sls data in green
shows the aggregation behavior of your
protein
and reports the temperature when
aggregation begins as a ta
you'll notice that the tag event lines
up with cm2 which is a link between the
second
unfolding event and the aggregation
event of the protein
so together the two protein tools of
intrinsic fluorescence and sls
give you a good understanding of how
unfolding and aggregation is occurring
in response to thermal stress of protein
dynamic light scattering or dls which is
uncle's third detection method
is a highly sensitive technique to give
you data on your protein's size and size
distribution
here we're looking at some example data
of a monomeric sample in blue
a sample with some aggregation in green
and a sample with significant
aggregation in yellow
i want to point out that the x-axis is
in a log scale
the metrics that are reported from dls
data are typically the average diameter
which is a weighted average of diameter
for the whole
sample population and a polydispersity
index value
or pdi which is a measure of the width
of the side's distribution
but higher pdi values tell you poly
disperse samples of many different sizes
and lower pdi values tell you a monodis
first sample
of the single size looking left to right
across the slide at these samples
we see an increasing trend in the
sierra's diameter which agrees with what
we know about the sample state as
aggregation increases
likewise the science distribution for
these samples widen as you look left to
right
so since higher pdi values indicate
wider size distributions
pdi would also show an increasing trend
here
in this case the sample on the left is
actually done at close to room
temperature
and the temperature increases to the mid
70 degrees celsius
once you've gotten all the way to the
right which is how we drove aggregation
from the sample
so using these tools can get you from a
multitude of choices
to finding the option that you really
want and now ron and adam will introduce
b2s life sciences
and speak about uncle's role in critical
reagent characterization
good afternoon everyone ron bauscher
here it's my pleasure to
talk with you today uh and my colleague
adam kenny about the
the application of the uh
unchained labs uncle instrument as an
advanced protein characterization
tool in our toolbox for uh evaluation of
critical reagents
my background uh in this business is
a span of roughly 30 years in
pharmaceutical industry
and about 20 years after retirement
and the focus of my career has been
mostly around biotherapeutics
and uh and today we we have a business
bts life sciences
that i'm going to offer a few comments
about
okay uh to begin our focus is on
critical reagents and i like to talk
about the criticality
of of critical reagents and what i'm
what i mean there is this the definition
is the state
or quality or the degree of something
being of highest importance
the the the fda today defines critical
reagents
as a requisite component in an assay
and uh as with the emergence of
biotechnology derived drugs
there's greater reliance today uh on
on critical reagents and commensurate
with that gr uh rely
greater reliance is a need for a well
good characterized and will be a
critical reagents
hence uh the mission for b2s large
sciences
who can reinforce the importance of
critical reagents
uh there was uh of uh several years ago
there was a
flurry of activity around the
reproducibility
crisis which which brought a
greater awareness to the to the concern
around the reproducibility and of the
quality
for commercially derived antibodies and
critical reagents
hence a need for the consumer
to provide better characterization
to ensure that they're suitable for
their intended purpose
in addition the over time the
the fda and the emea have both increased
their their awareness their
requirements expectations around how we
manage our our critical reagents for
supporting ligand binding assays and
as shown in this slide there's verbiage
around
how those requirements have evolved over
time
and the latest fda guidance document
again refers to critical reagents as
requisite components that require
uh management as well as
uh good documentation and uh and
as part of that requirement we offer
services to
help characterize and manage critical
reagents
to ensure that they meet regulatory
expectations
our mission here at b2s life sciences is
is
the design the generation the
purification
the characterization and life cycle
management
of custom critical reagents and with
complementary downstream activities in
essay development
but the goal here ultimately for
critical
reagents is is to enable successful
regulatory submissions of
biotherapeutics so we're providing
custom services for to our clients
for their critical reagents and in order
to do this
we we rely heavily on the uncle
instrument for advanced characterization
the the focus at b2s is
commensurate with the emphasis on
critical reagents our emphasis is
upstream
from typical bioanalytical cross so
we're focused on reagents
and acid development as opposed to being
focused or or emphasizing
sample analysis
so we have a tiered approach that we
have
adapted at b2s
and the this the tier one are our
standard characterization
for a current critical reagent and uh
includes a an assessment of care
concentration
assessment of purity an assessment of an
incorporation ratio
or a conjugate testing
if if it's a conjugate and then a
complimentary with that
is an activity or affinity assessment uh
for binding or what have you um when we
need
advanced characterization when issues
arise when
questions develop we then uh
have a set of advanced tools
in which we uh assess we can assess
size heterogeneity stability purity
and binding kinetics and as as i said
the
uncle platform is a is a key element
in that advanced testing
what i want to do now is turn it over to
adam kenny
who's going to offer a couple of
of very good case studies where
the uncle instrument has proved to be uh
uh highly valuable uh in being able to
make
time efficient uh dated data-driven
decisions
about our customers project
[Music]
thank you for that introduction ron
keeping with the theme i'm going to run
through my
background very quickly i'm a scientist
at b2s life sciences
in the custom reagents group prior to
coming to b2s i had eight years of
experience as a
synthetic chemist engaged in small
molecule work
uh both organic and inorganic species
and then my time in the
life sciences industry is a little bit
newer
uh focusing on protein chemistry and
critical reagents
so it wasn't a huge leap from small
molecule
but um i've
since moved a little bit upstream into
purification and characterization
so today we're presenting two case
studies
where the uncle instrument has aided our
characterization through advanced
characterization
methods and what those outcomes were
and key learning uh points from
each case study so the first case study
examines the advanced characterization
of
one enzyme which was produced and
provided to us
by two vendors we had reason to believe
that
the two isotimes differed in biochemical
behavior and warranted a closer look
so we chose our advanced
characterization
methods accordingly
and gathered data
to make their conclusions
so on this slide i
present the study design for
this case study we were seeking to learn
three key things about the enzymes what
composition stability and activity were
so on the composition point we were
looking to
tell what was in the samples that we
received
the stability uh we wanted to examine it
based on how well the
enzymes would respond to stresses and
the activity uh we wanted to
measure how well enzymes bound to the
antibodies which we're using
in the biochemical assays
so for the composition and stability we
use the
uncle instrument and
uh for the activity we used the octet
instrument which is a bli instrument
produced by a different manufacturer
one of the
so moving into the data analysis
portion of this case study we
first analyzed the vendor one enzyme
uh using the size and poly dispersity
method on the uncle platform
this is a dynamic light scattering
method so dls
and this generates three plots
in our configuration so on the left you
have the intensity distribution
which gives you the hydrodynamic
diameter that kevin introduced earlier
and the amplitude on the y-axis
on the right-hand side top you have the
correlation function
which is a mathematical representation
of the scattering pattern within the
sample
and then on right hand side bottom you
have the mass distribution which is a
corrective representation of the
population within the sample
so moving on to
the uh vendor two
data set you can see that the uh
hydrodynamic radius
or hydrodynamic diameter is shifted much
to the right indicating that there are
a large portion of
rather large particles in this material
what that means to us
is that this material was probably
aggregated as
received um so
if you look at the mass distribution
it's all over the place
and uninterpretable but the correlation
function
and the intensity just distribution
uh indicate that the by and large the
predominant species are
large particles
so one criterion which
kevin introduced but was not evident on
those
uh previous slides is the pdi
so that again that's the polydispersity
and index
and it is a measure of the uniformity of
a sample
so if you look at the vendor one
material it has a lower pdi
which indicates a higher uniformity
and if you also look at the
mode diameter of the first piece um
that would be corresponding to the
monomeric protein
uh is much smaller so under 10
nanometers for the diameter
and the mass percentage of it
is nearly 100 but
with the vendor 2 material
what would be referred to as the peak 1
in
the vendor 1 material is absent and
the peak one in the vendor two material
has a diameter
of greater than a thousand nanometers
and there's also a greater
polydispersive index
indicating poorer uniformity
so after we collect the dls data
we often uh use the same samples within
the same uni
to perform a tm study so this is
a thermal stability by way of
uh melting point or melting temperature
which we often shorten as tm
and as kevin mentioned in the top of the
presentation
this is essentially measuring the
intrinsic fluorescence of a protein
as a function of temperature
so examining the data for the two
vendor enzymes again we see a stark
contrast between the two data sets on
the left-hand side we have the vendor
one material
tm curve which shows the
normal sigmoidal morphology
and then on the right hand side we have
the vendor 2 tm curve which
essentially looks like noise so we don't
get
a real tm value for that
um the uh
the melting point for the vendor one
material was about 58 degrees c
and uh essentially what
what we uh concluded from
examining the vendor 2 material was that
it was likely unfolded or aggregated as
received which is consistent with the
dls data
the final point that we wanted to look
at
in this case study was the antibody
binding
selectivity so for this one we used the
forte bio bli instrument
essentially this instrument measures the
changes in interference patterns on a
surface
as a function of ligand binding
in this experiment we immobilized the
enzymes from vendor 1 and vendor 2 onto
a biosensor
and then supplied monoclonal antibodies
against the enzyme to the biosensors
and measured the interference pattern
so if we break down this these plots
into left and right hand side the left
hand side
is measuring the association so you have
a growing signal as more antibody binds
to the enzymes and then on the right
hand side you have dissociation where
signal decays as the antibody starts to
dissociate from from the biosensor
and then if you compare the blue and red
traces
blue traces being the vendor 1 material
and red traces being the vendor 2
material
you notice that the association values
were much higher
for the vendor 1 material and
the dissociation curves
are also correspondingly higher
so what that tells us is that more
antibody was binding to the vendor one
material
and then dissociating away from it
and there's a approximately a nine-fold
increase
in selectivity for the vendor one
material
so wrapping up uh
the first case study it was an
opportunity for us to use
the uh uncle instrument
to apply advanced characterization to
two enzymes
which were
[Music]
exhibiting differential behavior in
biochemical assays and the uncle
instrument was
the only tool that we had available here
which could give us
a clear answer on why this was happening
um and by using the dls and tm
applications we were able to choose the
best ice design for use in our critical
assays
so moving on to our second case study
the goal of this study
was to characterize and select
or support candidate selection for a
series of pegulated protein conjugates
and essentially the idea was
that we were supplied with a
series of pegulated enzymes which
advanced characterization was required
again we have a study design slide
for this case study to define the scope
of it
we received uh one
unpiglet or the parent unpegulated
enzyme and then four pegulated
variants of it they
are referred to as candidates one
through four for the pegulated enzymes
and candidates one through three have
similar
uh short short chain peg modifications
where
candidate four has a much larger
branched peg chain
um so that distinction will
be important throughout this case study
and
as with the previous case study we used
the dls
and tm applications
of the uncle
so the first step we
approached in this case study was to
characterize the unpegulated enzyme
first
and this
this sample and all of the candidates
were run in parallel thanks to the
the uni sample holder that kevin
introduced
we were able to run all of them
simultaneously
so if we look at the
unpegulated protein data here we have
an average diameter of about six
nanometers and a mud diameter of about
four and a half which is consisted with
a
monomeric protein and then
by looking at the mass distribution uh
we were able to determine that there was
less than one percent
uh high molecular weight species and the
pdi
of uh 0.19 indicates that the
enzyme was monodispersed so highly
uniform
so moving on to the number of candidates
candidates one through three again these
are the short chain
pegs modified enzymes
when we were examining the dlls data
they were all pretty similar the
diameters were
between 13.6 and 14
nanometers for the average diameter and
then
right around 13 for all of the mode
diameters
the pdis were all indicating
monitors birth samples so in
in this data set they they all looked
more or less the same
and then moving on to candidate four you
can see that
the intensity distribution shows
essentially no high molecular weight
species
the mass distribution peaks
all overlay really well and the
correlation function
over overlays pretty much perfectly
if when you look at the
diameters as well they're significantly
larger than
small peg derivatives and larger still
than the
unpegulated protein which is all
consistent with expectation
and the polydiversity index of this one
was also the best
indicating the highest uniformity of any
of the number
candidates
so bringing it all together this is a
table of the dls data
taken before uh the melting point
determinations
um you can see that we went from 6
to 13 to almost 16 in terms of the
average diameters
and then the mode diameters go from 4.6
to about 13 to about 17.
and this is so far
all consistent with our expectations
so digging a little bit deeper into how
the
the tm experiment works essentially
once you have your plot of the bcm
fluorescence
if you also plot the differential
so the cell and red trace and all of
these plots
whenever these hit a peak maximum that
defines
a phase change or melting point in this
experiment
one of the interesting things that came
out of these data sets was that
only the unpegulated enzyme showed the
second
tm uh which um
from a structural standpoint we're not
able to say
exactly what's happening there but it
appears as though the pegulation
eliminates the second melting
temperature
so um if we look at the statistics for
for all these experiments they all had
less than one percent cv
which uh a good
precision and minimal well the wall
variability
so
we move on to the uh
individual plots of the thermal melting
of the four numbered candidates
candidates one through three a look
uh essentially the same the tm is
about 48. um so 48.2
to 48.6 the candidate four
again with the larger peg is slightly
higher indicating a slightly improved
conformational stability but it also has
another
spectral feature where there is an
additional equilibration event at the
low temperature region
so about 15 to 45 degrees
there's a small hump in the bpm
fluorescence
and then tabulating the data we're able
to
compare all the metrics directly
the unpegulated protein had a slightly
higher tm1
than any of the number of candidates um
this isn't
anything really to worry about um
so um this is just uh
essentially to show that the tm1
is actually a pretty tight distribution
here
so one one other metric that we
studied in this uh in this case but
didn't uh discuss in the previous one
is the static light scattering or sls
using the 266 nanometer laser
uh the purpose of this analysis is to
uh detect and quantify small molecular
weight aggregates
so that would be particles that would
scatter 266 nanometer light
so these
these traces show uh some uh
notable morphological differences so
in this slide i've only presented uh
candidate two
and the unpegulated enzyme but
um you can see that the
aggregation temperature is shifted about
four degrees to the right
indicating it improves colloidal
stability of
the number candidate against the
pegulated enzyme
this is probably the most important
uh piece of data in this in this case
this is probably the the largest
difference between
uh unpegulated enzyme and any of the
candidates
so if we look at all four of the
numbered candidates
you can see that candidates 1 and 2
are about the same and
candidates 3 and 4 have a
slightly improved colloidal stability
with candidate four being the best and
uh notably canada four again
is the the large peg so we
were concluding that the uh larger peg
modification length
the best improvement in colloidal
stability
so moving on to the data summary
you can see that going from the
unpegulated enzyme
at 39 addition of
any of the short pegs gave you
about a four to five degree increase
in stability and then
conjugating the enzyme with the large
peg
modification gave about slightly more
than seven degrees
in improvement and considering
that the uh native protein
melts at about 40 degrees this is a
significant improvement
so bringing it all together uh
to summarize the second case study
um the different peg groups uh
influenced both the conformational
conformational
and colloidal stability in this case
study
the largest peg group gave the highest
conformational stability as well as
colloidal stability and
as expected uh pegulation will increase
the average particle size
of any protein and uh
the pegulated derivatives also showed
smaller pdis indicating that
their particle size distributions were
or
more homogeneous and
um in terms of putting it in context
the the uncle platform uh played a
very crucial role in an early phase
drug development project so um
that leads us into our overall
conclusions
which as you've seen over the course of
the last two case studies
the uncle instrument has on many
occasions
proved to be a key instrument in our
critical reagent characterization
toolbox uh
for our advanced characterization
activities
um and this especially comes into play
when
uh such investigations are needed to
augment
or um sometimes even
replace more traditional uh
characterization methods
um and the instrument has proved to be
indispensable
uh in our biophysical
and stability assessments um
especially uh whenever there are
difficult to answer questions about
client critical reagents and
our use of the instrument has been
growing commensurate
with the
increasing structural diversity and
complexity of
contemporary biotherapeutics
so thank you all for your time and
attending our
webinar uh we'll now field questions
from the attendees and presented here
are all of our contact information
if you would like to reach out and
discuss
any points beyond the q a session
thank you for your time
thank you dr bauscher adam and dr lance
for your informative presentation
we would like to now welcome dr sanofire
abdeen
to join us for the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
during the tm measurements of the
unpegulated
enzymes how many replicants did you use
to calculate the percent cv
so we typically use a four measurements
more the better
but it's depending on the sample
quantity so in this case we used a full
sample
okay thank you santa far uh looks like
we've got
a question here for dr lance
how can we measure the tm of proteins
large peptides that lack aromatic amino
acids
yeah so as i mentioned kind of in the
introduction section
we use a uv laser to excite aromatic
amino acids
but not every protein has that so it's
pretty easy to use dyes like cypro
orange
and add those to a thermal stability
experiment and when you do that
you use uncle's blue laser which excites
that dye and then as
proteins unfold that dye binds and
fluorescence from the die changes so
it's pretty easy to still look at those
other proteins if they do not have
aromatic amino acids
okay thank you dr lance we have another
question here
what would be the minimum shift in tag
or tm temperature
between samples that you would consider
significant to have a definitive
conclusion
improved stability uh of a decreased
stability
okay so i can probably take a first step
at this question and then
um maybe a b2s can weigh another
approach as well
so this is first kind of a statistical
question i would say it depends on
you know what's the variability in your
sample so
it's kind of understanding if two
populations are different but if you
just need a rule of thumb
then thinking about differences in you
know one to two degrees celsius is that
that's where they start to become you
know i would say
put into different buckets between uh
your best performers and maybe your next
tier
and your next tier
yeah to jump on that a little bit uh i
i would treat one to two degrees is uh
where we start to consider things to be
different
um we usually report the values to
one tenth of one degree so
um if like kevin was saying uh
it also kind of depends on the precision
of the measurement
okay fantastic thank you looks like i
have another question here for dr
lance you said that your laser for
intrinsic fluorescence
is at 266 nanometers
isn't it tryptophan excitation usually
at 280 nanometers
so this is a pretty common question
about the uncle
so tryptophan excitation peaks at 280
nanometers
but it's actually quite broad so if you
excite with the uv laser at 266
nanometers
what you're also getting is the ability
to see tearzing fluorescence as well
because that 266 will excite the
tryptophan and the tyrosine fluorescence
but by exciting at a at a lower
wavelength
you're actually creating a little bit of
space where that tyrosine fluorescence
can appear at about 280 nanometers
itself
on the shoulder of a tryptophan
excitation if you excite with 280
nanometers
uh you're not going to see that tyrosine
peak uh
because it's going to be overshadowed by
the larger tryptophan peak
so it's kind of a neat little way that
we have to take a look at both
tryptophan
and tyrosine residues independently
while still exciting both with a pretty
efficient excitation wavelength
thank you for that answer dr lance we've
got another question here
let's see on the evaluation of size and
supply disparity was the data generated
during the heat ramp or
at a different temperature
so the data was uh generated at the room
temperature
in addition to that we also typically
collect
dls data at the initial and the endpoint
of the
tm or tag analysis so that is the 15 and
95 that is the typical but the data
which we presented
was we measured the stability at room
temperature
fantastic thank you santa far another
question for dr lance
if proteins have the same melting
temperatures are you aware of examples
aggregation temperature difference yeah
are you aware of examples aggregation
temperature differs
uh yeah definitely so this actually
kind of gets into the neat reason why
having
fluorescence and sls on the same
instrument kind of adds insight
is because you can have proteins where
they
have the same melting temperature but
the aggregation temperature can differ
because maybe that aggregation event is
tied to
the first tm event in one protein but
the second tm
event in a different protein so it's
definitely something that can happen and
it's important to measure both of those
at the same time
so you can have both options to rank
your proteins by
great thank you so much for that answer
um next question
what is the protein amount in milligrams
needed for these kinds of applications
so it depends a little bit on the size
of your protein but say for example
if we're looking at an antibody protein
then we can go down to as little as .05
milligram per ml using only nine
microliters of sample
so we're talking about you know
micrograms of sample per
uh per i guess well per a unique cuvette
on the ankle
okay great i've got another uncle
question for you have you used
uncle for formulation development
shortly and then i'll take it up to b2s
uh so basically yes
uncle is used all the time by a lot of
customers for formulation development
and i think
you know ron definitely wants to speak
about the b2s experience
yeah so what i what i would say is i
think that the uncle
uh instrument is i an ideal platform
for doing that very thing and it's as
part of our
kind of vision for helping our clients
we we think that we can use the the
uncle
to you know develop formulations to
help stabilize other critical reagents
unfortunately we're so busy using it we
haven't had time to really do the
formal doe assessment but we're
confident that
that's actually a major uh benefit of
the technology
thank you ron for that thank you dr
bauscher it looks like i have another
question for the b2f folks here
of the different capabilities that the
uncle instrument possesses
which one has proved to be most
beneficial for b2s custom reagent
applications
so based on based on our experience we
found that that's
thermal or thermal or the confirmation
stability
and the aggregation stability data are
very important
and in addition to that this data can be
easily correlated to their function
of the critical region in the assay
development standpoint
in case of any pharmacokinetics or toxic
kinetics or ada assay development
purposes
so for example if your protein or ada
anti-drug antibody positive control is
unfolded
then you would be immediately directly
see some sensitivity
issue in your essay in addition to that
if you see
any aggregation then it has been
increasingly uh you could clearly see in
assa performance and
high background so i feel like those are
the two most important uh
factors that we routinely use for the
ankle platform
thank you so much santafar for that
answer
i have another question for b2s
what are the custom reagent capabilities
of b2s
[Music]
our range of services uh spans
in antibody generation
design uh purification
cycle management or critical reagents of
and we have a lot of tools uh in
addition to the uncle that we
use you know daily for a
characterization
so it i would say in in a nutshell
it's the design and generation
characterization and then we have a very
elaborate
life cycle management proprietary
system for providing life cycle
management so
um live critical reagents as adam
said um kind of is at the core of what
what we do thank you
thank you uh dr bauscher let's see we've
got another question
for dr lance regarding the uncle
how closely do uncle derived tm values
match those determined by dsc
also in the dls data shown for case
study 1
was the different trace traces in those
plots due to different temperatures
okay so i think uh for the dls data
question i think that one was answered
in the previous question where we
mentioned that those are done at kind of
room temperature
but addressing uncle and dsc so that
one's
pretty interesting because uncle data
correlates pretty well with dsc but
they're actually measuring slightly
different things
where dsc will measure a protein
physically moving and shifting in
response to heating
uh uncle's measurement by fluorescence
is
optically looking at when different
fluorescent
domains of your protein are changing so
you can expect a little bit of a
difference between those two behaviors
you could have movement that is not
impacting any kind of fluorescent amino
acid
and likewise uh individual fluorescent
amino acids that move and shift
like say if you have an individual
tryptophan residue that gets buried
that might not register uh you know as a
very large event by dsc as well
okay thank you so much dr lance let's
see we've got another question here
the first case study compares the
characterization of two enzymes
why do you only use two why not three or
more
so i can take that one
the short answer is only two were
available
and we we were evaluating them
uh post post purchase so
um we observed uh different behavior
and assay and wanted to dig in
uh a little bit to see why they were so
different even though they were
nominally the same enzyme
okay thank you so much for that answer
let's see it looks like we may have
another question um
how does b2s decide if advanced
characterization
is needed for a custom reagent
so i can go ahead and take that one too
um essentially
we evaluate it on a case-by-case basis
we try to fit our characterization plans
as well to the client needs as well as
what makes uh sound scientific sense
so for questions
that are rooted in what a
protein's overall structure might be
and you know whether it's folded
unfolded what not
uncle is a good choice for that um but
we also offer
another a number of other services uh
that we use for different cases
perfect thank you so much um let's see
let me check like we have another
question here
um what would you say is an experimental
limitation in alcohol
any constraints
so one thing that comes up with uncle is
if you're using these three detection
methods
of fluorescence static light scattering
and dls
the one that's pretty common emissive
from that list is actually uv biz for
concentration measurements
so if you're have kind of a sample that
maybe is coming off of a chromatography
column or there might be another reason
why you aren't certain of its
concentration then that's something that
you would typically check with uv vis
and so that's what we have other
instruments uh like the lunatic
where they take two microliters of
sample and get concentration and then
you can take a further nine
and run that and uncle and get all these
answers on stability
and aggregation so that's kind of just
another
technique that people really commonly
use side-by-side with uncle
that's also helpful to know when you're
kind of normalizing all these different
experiments and samples together
perfect thank you for that answer i have
a few more questions
does let's see if this is word does peg
harm the sample to or can harm can peg
harm the sample
so it is totally depend on the where we
make the conjugation so here
we took a native enzyme and conjugate it
to a protein
up to a peg so it's depending on the
amino acid residue that's
used for the conjugation is important
for the stability
so for example if there's a cysteine is
involved for the stability or the
conformational folding
and if you reduce the cysteine and
conjugate it to a pegality pick
then that could potentially unfold your
protein and reduce your stability
so for example if you use a lysine that
is on the surface
and it is not essential for the
stability and if you use that to
conjugate to a peg
then you might not see such a thermal
stability
issues was conjugated versus
unconjugated part
molecules so it is totally dependent on
what is the residues that if you use
to conjugate the molecule
thank you so much it looks like we're
out of time for questions so
thank you dr bauscher adam dr lance and
dr abdeen
do you have any final comments for our
audience
i would just like to say thank you
everyone for attending
uh lots of great questions
likewise adam i i see a number of
friends online and i would just want to
say hello and thank you for attending
absolutely thank you very much for an
engaging webinar
well thank you again dr bauscher adam dr
lance and dr abdeen for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
unchained labs for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
please join us for unchained labs next
webinar
broadcasting on february 11th at 8 a.m
pacific
11 a.m eastern keep it small
aav and lnp quant and sizing from
just micro leaders we hope to see you
there
until next time goodbye